lebanon's information minister has just
announced his resignation in an attempt
to resolve a stat with saudi arabia and
other gulf states the dispute was caused
by comments made by george
he was appointed less than three months
ago about
the comments were made concerning the
war in yemen
said the houthi rebels were defending
themselves in their fight against the
saudi-led coalition
riyadh banned all lebanese imports and
recalled its ambassador
let's bring in zainab she's live for us
in beirut so we've had this resignation
announced what reason
did
officially give for why he's resigning
well according to the information
minister he said after much thought i do
not want to be the reason why
there has been a deterioration in
relations between lebanon and its
traditional ally saudi arabia along with
other arab gulf states his comments
really that were aired in october
triggered the latest crisis but even
before his comments relations were
strained like you mentioned he called
the war in yemen a saudi aggression but
saudi arabia has repeatedly said that
the crisis is not in his comments but
the crisis is much bigger than that
saudi arabia believes that this country
is now under the control of iran and
that iran's ally in lebanon hezbollah
dominates decision-making in this
country so kardashia actually saying
that he is hoping that his resignation
will open the door to negotiations
opened the door to some mediation effort
in order to
resolve this crisis he does mention the
french president emmanuel macron who is
in the gulf and who will be visiting
saudi arabia tomorrow we understand that
macron really has been pressuring
authorities in lebanon to to get this
resignation done before he meets saudi
officials hoping really to use this as a
bargaining chip in efforts to resolve
the crisis now why is it so important
because of the timing lebanon economy is
in free fall the international community
if it is to help this country it will
need gulf money but saudi arabia making
it very clear that you know the
resignation is just not going to be
enough and they would like to see the
authorities contain really hezbollah
something that is going to be very
difficult to do so we have to wait to
see whether or not cordelia's
resignation as a goodwill gesture will
open the door to negotiations but a
deal really to solve this crisis it will
have to involve the regional tug of war
between iran and saudi arabia so how are
people there then taking in this
resignation after what was quite quite
some pressure from saudi arabia i think
banning imports
well there's mixed reaction there are
those who believe that he did not do
anything wrong he was expressing his own
personal opinion especially since he
made those comments when he was a knock
minister but of course there are others
here in lebanon who believe that iran's
control over the country through
hezbollah and its allies have led to the
isolation of of the lebanese state from
its traditional political and economic
partners you know the gulf they're the
main trading partners of lebanon and
when saudi arabia and other countries
decide to you know ban the import of
lebanese goods this is going to hurt
businesses and already this country is
reeling through one of its worst
economic crisis the currency has crashed
and and those in power are failing to
carry out the needed reforms in order to
unlock international aid france has been
trying to play a role in fact it was a
deal between france and the iranians
that led to the formation of the
government now the french need saudis on
board for much needed money
all right thanks so much